jason a marre de rester chez eux les
commerçants appareils sont en train de
perdre de l'argent il faut absolument
qu'on des confine assez rapidement parce
qu'il va y avoir un un énorme problème
économique
il est devenu nièce qui sont à l'école
et ils sont 40 par classe
ils sont 2000 dans son école dans une
cour de récréation j'étais pas comment
ils vont faire et donc je suis très
inquiète non seulement pour les adultes
ont également surtout pour les enfants
un problème nous dès qu'on finisse
protos saisir qu'il ya encore trop de
risques il est passé de pourcentage de
la population qui étaient atteints par
le virus qu'ils s'y soient immunisés
donc à partir de ce moment là je pense
que même s'il arrive un peu trop tôt de
toute manière il ya de fortes chances en
fait qu'il ya un deuxième continent par
la suite qui se rajoutent